escape room is the first new film of
2019 and as usual it's a horror thriller
of sorts last year that movie was
insidious the last key which for a
fourth film in the franchise was
actually not too bad it's from the same
director as escape room believe it or
not this film follows a group of people
who get involved in what they think is
an innocent game in which $10,000 is a
reward if they can escape this room
escape rooms are a thing now I mean you
can go to these places that have puzzles
there's Harry Potter themed ones there's
Star Wars themed ones they're getting
very big and eventually a movie was
bound to happen surrounding this concept
and this of course takes the idea of
what's normally viewed as a fun event
with friends and makes it our
life-or-death scenario I would say the
first 30 to 40 minutes of the film were
diverting enough the characters though
were very annoying one of the characters
actually says out loud wow I feel like
I'm playing the world's funnest game
with the world's meanest people because
most everyone in the film except for a
couple characters are total assholes
none of them seem like they want to be
there
despite the $10,000 reward even before
the game starts there's this vibe in the
room of anger and it kind of makes the
proceedings not fun because there's no
fun even before the bad shit starts to
happen you can't really enjoy watching
these people get involved in these
scenarios because they seem absolutely
miserable before the life-and-death
stuff happens and that could perhaps be
an attempt to endear us to these people
because it makes us feel for them
because we understand that their lives
haven't gone very well but it sort of
sucked all of the fun that could have
been had out of the earlier portion of
the movie but it was still watchable
enough like the first room is based
around heat the next is based around
cold the third room is actually my
favorite in the movie and it was really
entertaining and easily the best scene
in the film Deborah Han wolf from
daredevil who I love gets a lot to do in
this scene it's this upside-down room in
which the ceiling looks like the ground
but the grass
also looks like the ground there's pool
tables on the ceiling lamps on the
ceiling and the director Adam robitille
does a lot of interesting things with
the camera throughout this scene
twisting things around and playing with
your perception and I thought that was
actually really clever just about after
that though I think the film takes a
nosedive into
unintentionally hilarious territory and
I found the film to get considerably bad
after that to the point of cringe-worthy
sequences and an ending that was so so
disappointing and so out of left field
and very unnecessary that it was a
little bit maddening to be honest it's a
film that sets up questions and kind of
prides itself specifically the
screenplay on being really clever and
inventive and it makes you ask questions
about things you see early on a doctor's
name for instance and in the film tries
to tie this into things as the film gets
to the end but the film cops out and
leaves you with no answers and instead a
setup for a sequel that was just very
lame and so it's almost like they said
hey we've got you on the hook with these
interesting questions but we don't want
to bother ourselves with actually
crafting these answers into the film
we're just going to assume that
hopefully this makes enough money so
that we can get a sequel and then maybe
we'll address those questions in the
sequel but even if they do get a sequel
I'm not really seeing any of these
characters being in it again it's
probably just going to be another
straight-to-dvd sequel or if it does get
a theatrical sequel it'll probably just
be a new group of people this movie
feels very much like a pg-13 version of
saw combined with the movie cube if you
ever seen cube it's a sci-fi film with a
group of people that are stuck in a cube
and every single room has these puzzles
that they have to solve so they can
advance farther and farther into the
cube and hopefully escape this movie is
a mash-up of those things especially
once you discover certain things that
are going on under the surface the way
the film wraps up was just so
horrendously disappointing and it felt
very much a ripoff of other things that
we've seen a thousand times as horror
fans the characters themselves also
really don't
save the movie because there's very few
of them that are likable and most of the
actors save for a few namely Debra Ann
will do a fairly awful job Tyler Labine
and Logan Miller these two actors were
pretty good as well but the rest of the
cast are very very weak so much so to
where it really just feels like acting
none of their emotions really feel
authentic especially our lead actress
who is apparently the main protagonist
she's on the poster and throughout the
movie you kind of get on her side of
things but she never really comes forth
in the film to to be the protagonist she
does very little of any real merit she
makes a couple smart choices there are
scenes where you can see that atom Robo
tell is talented and I did like
insidious the last key his film the
Taking of Debra Logan also did fairly
well on the indie horror circuit I think
he is a very talented filmmaker but this
very much so feels like a studio botched
job and that's just my personal
impression I could be completely wrong I
think he's a talented director and I
want to see what else he does but the
movie took such a drastic nosedive into
corporate sequel territory in which I
began to feel like I was watching a
movie that didn't give much of a shit
about creating anything of art or merit
or at least entertainment value and just
really wanted to make sure they could
start some kind of a franchise out of
this and the final scene is just
horrendous I have no idea what happened
that it felt like an entirely different
person suddenly started directing the
movie and it was just very confusing to
me this is very much so a first week of
January movie I'm gonna give escape room
adhi there are parts of the movie that I
found entertaining it's just that when
the film takes such a drastic turn
towards the end and kind of reveals
itself to be what it is it just lost me
after that guys thank you so much as
always for watching I'm looking forward
to some movies this January
namely glass the Dragon Ball super movie
the kid who would be king from the
director of attack the block that could
be interesting I'm looking forward to
seeing that guys thank you so much as
always for watching I'm looking forward
to another year of talking film with you
guys and making fun
and sharing them thank you so much guys
as always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
you